bon sens nous sommes jeudi 4 février
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour votre actualité locale
entouré de nous inviter mais également
des journalistes de la rédaction tout de
suite les titres de cette édition
faut-il signaler les conducteurs seniors
sur la route une idée qui fait débat
pour nous en parler ce soir gilles
renard président de l'association
signale seniors il propose un macaron s
similaire à celui des jeunes apprentis
conducteurs à 24 ans jean baptiste
lavergne mort à dagneux obtient sa
première étoile dans le guide michelin
reportage dans son restaurant la table
du bronze à versailles ouvert depuis
moins d'un an
et pour cette 8e édition du vendée globe
de versailles et éric bellion et tanguy
de lamotte s'élanceront depuis le port
des sables-d'olonne
retour sur leurs objectifs avec la
chronique de michael almy d'euros pour
commencer ce journal cette première
information la première réunion de la
cellule de lutte contre la
radicalisation organisé par le parquet
de versailles s'est tenu aujourd'hui une
assistante de radicalisation spécialiste
de la problématique a été recruté pour
épauler les magistrats dans leur tâche
elle collectera des informations se
déplacera dans les prisons également
dans les mairies ce groupe piloté par le
procureur de la république doit
permettre de mieux appréhender le
phénomène afin de mieux y répondre les
services de renseignements seront
également mis à contribution
une expérimentation qui se concentrent
pour l'instant uniquement sur la zone de
police du département elle est réalisée
en collaboration avec le parquet de
chartres
également confronté aux dérives de
l'islam radical et le plan numérique
présentée par le président de la
république le 7 mai 2015 se concrétise
dans les yvelines hier à guyancourt 51
nouveaux ambassadeurs du numérique en
milieu scolaire ont reçu un kit
numérique utilisable au quotidien en
classe sont avril 2015 60 enseignants
volontaires avaient déjà reçu ce kit
portant à 111 le nombre d'ambassadeurs
sur le territoire regardez ce reportage
signé william l
ils sont certainement les représentants
de l'école de demain
quand tu es un enseignant illinois promu
ambassadeur du numérique ont reçu
aujourd'hui leur kit de travail à
l'intérieur une tablette un vidéo
projecteur et un visualiseur par le
numérique on multiplie les entrées
possibles dans les savoirs scolaires et
on est plus attentif à la diversité des
apprentissages tel qu'il se joue dans
une classe avec des élèves qui
aujourd'hui grâce une approche parfois
plus ludique mais qui ne renonce pas aux
exigences scolaires pourront
s'approprier plus aisément des contenus
scolaires opérant zyl zone
d'intervention localisée une moitié de
ces enseignants remplaçants travail en
réseau d'éducation prioritaire
l'autre camp bureau ovale par fonctions
par vocation
ils ont à enseigner dans des écoles
différentes au cours d'une année
scolaire donc on se donne davantage de
chances de mettre des élèves en rapport
en contact avec ce type d'apprentissage
qui est novateur et qui permet encore
une fois aux élèves de mieux entrer dans
les apprentissages pour nombre d'entre
eux est réduit on passait dans le
numérique est conservé
une récompense oui une récompense et
puis surtout une curiosité pour voir un
petit peu ce qu'on va pouvoir faire avec
ce matériel pendant cet après midi les
ambassadeurs ont reçu une initiation
matériel qu'ils auront jusqu'au mois de
juillet un kit d'une valeur de 1300
euros prêtés par la déesse des haines
qui opérera également à la formation et
ont suivi des enseignants et on parle
beaucoup de prévention à l'intention des
jeunes conducteurs sur la route - à
propos des seniors pourtant ils
représentent 16 % des automobilistes en
france et sont impliqués dans 9 % des
accidents
nous allons en parler ce soir avec aj le
renard bonsoir vous êtes président de
l'association signale seniors merci
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
alors vous venez d'auteuil le roi dans
les yvelines et vous avez eu l'idée d'un
macaron est ce pour les seniors comme le
hac les jeunes conducteurs ont sur leur
pare-brise voilà je l'est dont les mains
ça se présente sous ce format 6 comment
est née cette idée vivent effectivement
dans les yvelines à auteuil dans un
milieu rural les force de côtoyer des
personnes âgées un jour on en discute
emmené oui pourquoi on n'a pas un petit
signe distinctif pour se faire
identifier sur la route donc du coup est
venue cette idée du us pour seniors
alors qu elle est un petit peu
l'objectif c'est de signaler les
personnes âgées ou les seniors voile à
partir de quel âge on peut se considérer
seniors alors bon allez c'est difficile
de parler d'âge mais effectivement au
delà je pense de 75 ans on a peut-être
un peu plus de difficultés beaucoup
moins de confiance au volant
donc l'idée c'est effectivement de
coller cette auto quand l'arrière du
véhicule pour être identifié des autres
automobilistes comme on peut l'être
effectivement et chloé ou même le logo
bébé à bord une jeune maman qui colle
cet autocollant envie d'être en sécurité
puisque avec ses enfants donc voilà le
le s pour être identifiés sur la route
donc c'est une demande qui vient de la
part des automobilistes de leur famille
commence à s'identifier alors au début
et effectivement nous avons
conçu cette idée pour les personnes
âgées directement et on s'est aperçu
très vite que c'est des familles
aujourd'hui qui nous contactent les
enfants et les petits enfants
parce que voilà j'ai une maman j'ai un
bon grand-père encore qui conduit il
manque un peu d'assurance souvent il se
fait klaxonner
on lui colle aux pare-chocs et on
aimerait qu'ils sont peu plus respectés
au volant du coup maintenant il beaucoup
de d'autocollants qui ont été distribués
et vendus donc maintenant les gens sont
un peu plus respectueuse vis-à-vis de
ces personnes âgées alors ce sont des
biens de qui vous contactent via le site
internet vous vendez ses macarons 4
euros exactement si je me trompe pas et
vendu déjà à plus d'un millier le doute
déjà maintenant on les double oui
justement ces personnes voilà vos
contacts vous leur envoyez mais c'est
vraiment au bon vouloir de chacun c'est
du volontariat
exactement il ya aucune obligation
aujourd'hui sur la sécurité des
personnes âgées
il ya pas dix médicale obligatoire il
n'y a pas de contrôle de concernant le
niveau de capacité aujourd'hui on
propose une alternative est quelque
chose de nouveau pour les sécuriser sur
la route alors justement nous sommes
allés à la rencontre des yvelinois des
habitants de saint quentin en yvelines
en leur demandant ce qu'il pensait de
cette idée d'un macaron sur les
pare-brise des seniors écouter leurs
réponses le s moi ça fait penser un peu
à sénile
c'est un peu gênant est ce qu'on a
vraiment une bonne vue sur nos
compétences de conducteurs sam est un
apport non donc je vois pas pourquoi on
peut conduire à 70 ans 75 ans après
c'est une question physique
je trouve ça un peu le brent un peu
ridicule ou quoi entre je sens bien je
vois pas du tout l'intérêt
honnêtement je pense surtout qu'à partir
d'un certain âge pourrait peut-être
repasser un genre de stage comme les
stages qu'on a pour les récupération de
points
juste pour vérifier qu'on est un peu à
jour sur le sur le code et puis aussi
bas les aptitudes physiques
éventuellement ça nous permet à nous
aussi d'identifier que la place d'une
personne âgée qui a moins de reflets ce
qu'on fait attention
alors on a vu où tous les bus à des
réponses plutôt voilà à négative
on va dire qu'ils sont comprennent pas
très bien vous comprenez ces réactions à
sa personne bah écoutez bon là on a
parlé de mots assez violent certainement
une personne qui habite en ville donc
qui a accès aux transports qui a eu
accès aux commerces
c'est pas du tout le cas des gens qui
vivent en zone rurale donc faut aussi
penser à eux
maintenant effectivement il ya la jeune
femme qui a parlé de visites médicales
ou mvno éventuellement de remise à
niveau
faut savoir que avec la main les
auto-écoles ça coûte 300 euros 300 euros
aujourd'hui pour avoir un minimum de
remise à niveau pour avoir un certain
jean l'a passé une heure de conduite
pour une personne pour un jeune
conducteur ou pour une personne âgée
c'est le même prix c'est 50 euros de
l'air il faut au minimum six heures 300
euros nous c'est 4 euros je pense que
c'est plus intéressant et moins coûteux
pour les personnes âgées qui ont des
budgets quand même assez limité donc je
pense que la première interrogés
disaient ça me fait penser à ces nil est
ce que justement ce n'est pas
stigmatisant pour les seniors
aujourd'hui comme j'ai expliqué les
seniors
on pensait qu'on allait vendre
directement enseignée aujourd'hui c'est
des familles alors est ce que les
familles pensent que l'or qu'on
stigmatise leurs parents je ne pense pas
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de retours sur
des commandes qui ont été passées
aujourd'hui les gens sont quand même
très satisfait ils sont quand même
identifié c'était quand même la première
démarche le but ultime
aujourd'hui on les remarque sur la route
donc du coup il n'y a aucune
stigmatisation de ce côté info je veux
rassurer les gens alors justement fin
vous travaillez beaucoup avec des
communes rurales parce que c'est vrai
que dans les communes rurales c'est une
grosse problématique les personnes âgées
sont dépendantes de leur véhicule c'est
un peu difficile peut-être deux voilà
d'appréhender cette problématique vous
essayé de contacter les communes
justement pour qu'elle essaie de mettre
en avant votre projet voilà donc il ya
les crs 1 souvent dans les mairies ou
directement la municipalité
effectivement le but c'est de
communiquer avec eux et qu'ils puissent
acheter l'autocollant et le mettre à
disposition de leurs administrés c'est
vraiment le l'objectif à court terme
mais c'est effectivement les gens nous
contactent nous voit effectivement à à
la télé par votre biais également et ne
savent pas où l'acheter donc personnes
âgées n'ont pas toujours accès donc
l'internet donc généralement ils vont
dans les bureaux de tabac ou dans les
magasins de proximité n'en trouve pas
donc du coup voilà je pense que la
mairie aujourd'hui est le meilleur moyen
pour se procurer le l'autocollant est ce
que plus largement pour aller un peu
plus loin l'objectif de votre
association sera aussi de faire évoluer
un petit peu les choses au niveau
législatif dans d'autres pays alors déjà
il faut savoir que le s le principe
d'identifier les personnes des personnes
âgées ça existe déjà au japon
au japon il ya déjà ce donc que vous
voyez mon papa des stigmatisations au
japon on appréhende on apprécie on aime
énormément les personnes âgées
ils l'ont mis en place ils l'ont imposé
ça s'imprime qui est réglé dans une
question de mentalité je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les jeunes sont habitués
avec l'autocollant du ha
et demain
entre les mairies les auto-écoles et
éventuellement les assureurs je pense
qu'on pourra le diffuser plus largement
c'est une première étape de prévention
est ce que plus globalement il vrai
qu'il ya une vrai encadrement justement
de la part du gouvernement
est-ce que le gouvernement va vouloir
imposer quelque chose comme on parlait
avis médical ça coûterait cher la sécu a
quand même des soucis de trésorerie
là les personnes âgées sont quand même
un électorat très beau temps donc est-ce
qu'ils vont oser toucher à cet électorat
est entre guillemets les titiller nous
on pense seulement qu effectivement une
communication vis-à-vis des autres
automobilistes est très importante parce
que aujourd'hui les personnes qu'ils
achètent ce à quoi ça correspond
c'est vrai que s'il y avait une
communication un peu plus large au
niveau des automobiles de chacun pour
que tout le monde sache à quoi
correspond le reste comme on peut l'être
au courant j'ai dû à voilà maintenant je
pense que l'alternative qui va être mise
en place par les parlers futur
gouvernement sera certainement la visite
médicale maintenant c'est un crs le
budget dont après la formation je veux
aujourd'hui ça reste du volontariat
encore une fois comme pour le s pourtant
il ya de plus en plus de personnes âgées
c'est une problématique 8e km pris en
compte il faudrait peut-être se faire
plus de choses et forcé un petit peu
pourquoi justement la prévention
routière on ne parle pas de ce sujet la
bonne question la prévention routière ne
à ce jour ne nous suit pas donc elle
nous elle nous elle redirige les gens
vers notre site et vers le notre numéro
de téléphone qui à disposition
effectivement elle communique pas pour
l'instant parce qu'elle a pas de
solution donc aujourd'hui aider des
campagnes de publicité pour les jeunes
pour les l'alcool au volant pour toutes
ces choses là mais le sujet des
personnes âgées et l'autonomie des
personnes âgées aujourd'hui c'est un
sujet que personne n'a voulu aborder
donc non laborde ça nous dérange pas je
comprends les effectivement les quelques
critiques et quelques jeux de mots
maladroits je trouve pas ce que je pense
pas que les personnes âgées soient
sénile bien au contraire l'impression
qu'ils sont là et ben on sait on a tous
un parents et grands parents dans dans
notre famille donc forcément
je pense que c'est important
qu'aujourd'hui les les personnes âgées
soient autonomes puissent rester dans le
cadre familial de leur maison plutôt que
de partir de la maison de retraite et
dans sa relation lors on leur coupe ce
lien social on leur enlève la voiture ça
n'ira pas je pense que c'est important
qu'il continue à lire à faire leurs
courses aller voir leurs amis puissent
aller à la pharmacie aller acheter leur
journal tout seul est ce qu'il ya une
étape une prochaine étape pour signer le
seigneur vous allez essayer de faire
autre chose d'aller un petit peu plus
loin alors leur et qui déjà de sept
heures de cette nouvelle initiative bas
cette initiative aujourd'hui la
prochaine étape justement que vous
expliquer c'est la diffusion donc il
faut savoir que l'autocollant est ce
pour seniors est aussi un sujet
intéressant en europe
on a déjà eu des contacts en angleterre
en allemagne en belgique donc des ventes
également dans ces pays là pourquoi
parce que c'est aussi un sujet qui qui
concerne aussi ces pays européens
maintenant ce qui nous concerne voilà
nous notre priorité c'est éventuellement
aussi travaillé que des assureurs parce
que s'ils vont y voir les mairies le
aujourd'hui s'il ya bien un domaine qui
touche la sécurité routière c'est aussi
hélas des assureurs il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui une personne âgée qui
conduit est assuré et toute personne qui
dans 90% des cas des personnes âgées qui
ont un accrochage je parle même pas
d'accident un accrochage arrête de
conduire donc là dans ce cas là bas
c'est un assuré qui part donc je pense
qu'aussi les assurances auraient tout
intérêt à proposer sont aussi sous forme
du volontariat
l'autocollant quand effectivement chaque
année sans voix le petit macaron vert
pour la petite vignette je pense que ça
serait intéressant qui le rejoignent
dans le courrier pour pouvoir le
proposer leurs leurs clients merci
beaucoup gilles renard d'avoir résolu la
note alors toutes ces informations et
notamment si vous souhaitez commander ce
petit macaron pour la poser à votre
pare-brise
vous retrouvez toutes les informations
sur le site internet www.syncsort.com
merci beaucoup lui et c'est une start up
qui a le vent en poupe et qui vient de
fêter ses cinq années d'existence la
jeune entreprise matrix think a débuté
son activité dont la pépinière
d'entreprises de versailles grand parc
aujourd'hui elle occupe des bureaux en
plein coeur de versailles une start up
innovantes qui se développe sur le
marché des logiciels pour les
entreprises comme l'expliquent william l
il ya plusieurs logiciels qui sont
nécessaires donc là on est en train via
le flux métiers de comprendre comment
tous ces logiciels doivent dialoguer
entre eux et ça c'est l'expression de
besoins qui ensuite est donné aux
équipes techniques pour un disque
réalisé tout cela d'un point de vue
technologique
une activité qui semble complexe mais
qui optimise pourtant le rendement des
entreprises
il y a cinq ans mathieu thoras créé sa
start up matrix 5
après des débuts dans la pépinière
d'entreprises versailles grand parc
mathieu dirige aujourd'hui une quinzaine
de salariés en plein centre de
versailles nous sommes dans une start up
dans les logiciels et nous attaquons au
cauchemar qu'ont nos clients qui est la
multiplicité de logiciels dont ils ont
besoin pour pouvoir être compétitif
aujourd'hui ces quatre cinq six
logiciels qu'une entreprise a besoin
pour être compétitif et il ya une vraie
problématique de connectivité de
transformer ses logiciels en flux
métiers le flux métiers une plateforme
qui regroupe tous les logiciels qu'une
entreprise utilise pour son
fonctionnement
mathieu analyse les besoins du client
achète les logiciels et les connecte
ensemble pour un site de e-commerce par
exemple logiciel de gestion commerciale
de stocks et de transport sont
regroupées en une seule plateforme
fournit clé en main à l'entreprise
l'objectif faciliter et optimiser le
rendement je peux vous annoncer que dans
les prochaines années
la problématique de l'automatisation du
logiciel va devenir un sujet majeur et
fars on est précurseur
on parle beaucoup ces derniers temps de
big data mais là on va parler de
l'automatisation des logiciels qu un
niveau de complexité et la un marché que
mathieu a saisi attentes sur l'exercice
2015 matrix 5 affiche un chiffre
d'affaires d'un million d'euros et des
signatures de contrats avec des clients
comme le téléthon ou l'oréal et parme en
gastronomie à présent le célèbre guide
michelin a annoncé cette semaine sa
sélection de restaurants étoilés pour
2016 dans les yvelines
un seul chef a été distinguée jean
baptiste lavergne mourad année à 24 ans
le chef de la table du 11 à versailles
obtient sa première étoile nous sommes
allés à se rencontrer directement dans
ses cuisines
regardez ce reportage avec des images
chine et william el est fanny bourdon
si les légumes mais je doucement la
cuisine de la table du 11 est en pleine
effervescence étoilé pour la première
fois par le guide michelin
le chef jean baptiste lavergne mots à
dany son équipe ont à peine eu le temps
de savourer cette récompense
mais sa reprise mais gelé de betteraves
boeuf argentin une cuisine gastronomique
sans fioritures ici la carte courte on
trouve un menu unique qui change tous
les quinze jours un travail sur les
textures vont respecter également les
saisons de la pêche des viandes à
l'afrobeat mais pour ça il ya des
saisons on travaille un maximum de bio
on va là on est sûr de la pêche durable
c'est dans l'air du temps à 24 ans jean
baptiste fait partie des plus jeunes
chefs étoilés
après avoir fait ses armes dans des
établissements est aussi distingué comme
le trianon palace ou encore le meurice
il décide d'ouvrir son propre restaurant
50 couverts en moyenne par jour
moins d'un an après le pari est un
succès restera-t-elle nous aurons un
territoire déjà plaint des clients qui
devrait se faire encore plus nombreux
une étoile son jeu presque la vie d'un
chef jean baptiste a encore du mal à le
réaliser
on va commencer par se poser un peu de
recul par rapport à tout ce qui est en
train de se passer
et puis là on tombe sur les bacs
concernées en vacances dans quinze jours
c'était déjà prévu donc je pense que ça
va faire du bien à tout le monde rendez
vous en avril pour les bourreaux mais
qui devront s'armer de patience pour
réserver à la table du 11
désormais le septième restaurants
étoilés des yvelines il est temps de
parler sport à présent nous recevons sur
ce plateau notre journaliste sportif
puisqu'elle et demi d'euros pour la
chronique sport du g10 bonsoir michael
bon surf lorraine alors aujourd'hui nous
allons parler
cyclisme la coupe d'hiver
d'ile-de-france est programmée ce samedi
6 février au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines pour lui parler de
ce rendez-vous nous recevons sur ce
plateau jérémy fromonteil qui est
l'organisateur de cet événement bonsoir
c'est ça mon jour alors quelles seront
les épreuves au programme de ce rendez
vous alors on a des épreuves
essentiellement d'endurance sur ce
premier rendez vous hivernal sur sur le
vélodrome avec des épreuves pour pour
tous on va avoir des épreuves jeunes à
partir de la catégorie minime donc à
partir de 12 ans jusqu'au jusqu'aux
seniors des loisirs et des coureurs qui
font de la compétition sur du c'ur du
haut niveau donc à l'omnium par exemple
qui sera leur programme alors c'est un
omnium parce que c'est une combinaison
un des preuves ce n'est pas johnny deep
du du due forme olympique
c'est un homme plutôt typé endurance
donc plusieurs épreuves vont avoir lieu
pour chacun des concurrents au cours d'
au cours de la journée donc des épreuves
spectaculaires qui devrait plaire au
public
on devrait avoir des épreuves
spectaculaires on a maintenu
l'américaine qui est l'une des épreuves
les plus spectaculaires pour pour nous
sur piste qui aura lieu et qui conclura
le spectacle lors de cette journée et
vous attendez du monde dans les tribunes
pour cet événement on espère comme
d'habitude avoir comme les années
précédentes
au moins 500 personnes qui remplissent
le vélodrome n'hésitez pas à venir voir
les coureurs ce samedi on aura du
spectacle comme je vous dis sur tout
tout l'après midi et c'est gratuit c'est
gratuit le cyclisme est un sport qui
culturellement
1 et populaire donc on reste sur cet
accès gratuit pour un pour tous sur
cette journée et c'est une épreuve
plutôt pour les cyclistes confirmés ou
pour les petits jeunes qui débutent dans
sa vision du coup ce qu'est ce qui est
intéressant sur cette épreuve régionale
c'est qu'on va en avoir pour un pour
tout le monde
on a dû public loisirs qui fait de la
compétition pour son loisir on a du
public jeunes qui aspirent justement à
rentrer dans nos équipes nationales est
allé au plus haut niveau
on a du public qui déjà concours sur des
championnats internationaux sur des
championnats de france on a la chance
d'avoir la participation d'un beau d'un
beau plateau
donc il y aurait été de la fiche on aura
quelques têtes d'affiché nationales on
aura surtout un loris berton qui on lui
souhaite fera ses premiers tours de
piste avant d'aller aux jeux olympiques
à rio
cet été et c'est une super opportunité
pour les jeunes qui vont qui vont
débuter qui est de concourir dans ce
vélodrome national de saint-quentin
voilà ici hein c'est l'objectif est
également de cet événement oui c'est un
des plus beaux outils qu'on puisse
savoir en france c'est un outil qui
prépare un autre jeunesse justement
aller vers le plus haut niveau c'est un
outil qui amènent les jeunes cyclistes à
la piste donc c'est un passage important
et une opportunité de pouvoir rouler sur
le vélodrome que quand même accueilli
les championnats du monde l'année
l'année passée nous rouler sur la même
piste que les grégory baugé que les
thomas boudât pour nos jeunes c'est
important donc ce sera la troisième
édition
est-ce qu'il y en aura d'autres on le
souhaite dans le futur on souhaite que
ça continue on souhaite qu'il y en ait
qui en est plus aujourd'hui on arrive à
avoir une de compétition sur un sur
l'hiver d'envergure régionale
on souhaite en mettre d'autres et faire
vivre ce vélodrome pour les coureurs de
la région pour ensuite pouvoir se
développer au niveau national merci
d'être passé sur ce plateau bon courage
pour l'organisation je le rappelle la
coupe d'hiver est programmée ce samedi 6
février de 10 heures à 19 heures 30 au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines florame et on donne après
un petit coup de dans votre
chronique pour passer aux autres
rendez-vous du week-end me tienne nous
allons parler maintenant de football
américain les templiers reprennent le
chemin des terrains ce week-end et oui
c'est la reprise florane les templiers
d'elancourt qui évoluent dans le
championnat élite l'équivalent de la
première division française reçoivent
les gladiateurs de la queue-en-brie à
domicile pour ce début de saison
la rencontre est programmée ce samedi à
20 heures au complexe sportif europe les
templiers devrait être favori de la
rencontre ils ont un côté dans leurs
rangs un américain jesse roddick qui
devrait les propulser cette année dans
le haut du classement
le quarterback titulaire sera de
jonathan hickman ce qui est considéré
comme l'un des meilleurs joueurs du
championnat
tous les voyants sont donc au vert pour
les templiers d'elancourt cette saison
on leur souhaite évidemment de ramener
le titre de champion france à l encours
après le foot us on termine cette
chronique par du badminton c'est le
rendez vous à ne pas manquer pour les
passionnés de badminton le 15e tournoi
international de double est organisée
pour parler volant d'elancourt ce
week-end au palais des sports de la
ville les meilleurs joueurs du
département seront présents le samedi
des doubles dames et hommes seront
organisées de 8h30 à 21h des finales se
dérouleront en fin de journée à partir
de 18h les dimanches place au double
mixte
les badistes s'affronteront de 8h30 à
18h plus de 200 spectateurs sont
attendus pour l'événement et peut-être
vous floral
je sais que vous avez fait du badminton
dans votre jalousie qu'elle vous êtes
bien renseigné mais vous savez je
n'étais pas très doué à l'époque
justement j'en profiterais peut-être
pour demander quelques conseils aux
bâtisses à ce week-end on vous retrouve
dans quelques instants pour votre taux
le question parler du sport quel sera le
programme a dit moir bas les
chroniqueurs sont dans les loges ils
sont prêts à en découdre florane nous
parlons notamment de football américain
et ben bal avec plaisir et je vous
laisse la surprise pour les autres
téléphones sont dans les loges sont déjà
pensé que comme on l'avait enregistré
plus de sa mission et il me tarde de la
regarder entre cas et de la découvrir
on continue à présent dans le sport avec
un sujet que vous avez tourné michael la
présentation des concurrents du prochain
vendée globe l'équivalent de la coupe du
monde de la voile était organisée ce
mercredi à paris ils seront 27 skipper à
s'élancer des sables d'olonne le 6
novembre prochain parmi eux deux
versaillais
éric bellion et tanguy de lamotte un
reportage signé michael et demi d'euros
et fanny bourdon
une flotte de 27 skipper de neuf
nationalités prendra le départ de la
huitième édition du vendée globe 2016
annonce a été faite à paris pendant la
cérémonie de présentation de l'épreuve
parmi les concurrents de versailles et
tanguy de lamotte et éric bellion le
premier participera pour la deuxième
fois la compétition en 2013 les lillois
avaient terminé à la 10e place
comme la dernière fois ça sera de finir
la course dans l'objectif sportif qui
serait de faire le tour du monde en 80
jours avec ce bateau et avec le temps de
préparation que j'ai eu c'est quelque
chose de possible c'est un objectif
réaliste qui est élevé mais réaliste de
son côté éric bellion sera nos vies sur
cette course mythique après sa septième
place sur la transat jacques vabre 2015
le versailles et s'attaque à ce tour du
monde en solitaire
au niveau sportif c'est clair c'est que
c'est terminé la course en étant fier de
moi c'est à dire en ayant donné le
maximum et en ayant le plus beau
résultat que je puisse avoir
je ne connais pas encore maintenant on
verra en fonction les abandons etc
mais c'est vraiment de finir la course
en ayant en n'ayant pas triché les deux
versailles et prendront le large le 6
novembre prochain des sables d'olonne
les skippers heavy loi succéderont
peut-être à françois gabart vainqueur de
l'épreuve en 2013 en 78 jours et nous
suivrons évidemment le parcours de nos
deux versailles et avec attention
c'est à présent la fin de cette édition
je vous remercie de nous avoir suivis
demain vous avez rendez vous avec
wilfrid richy pour l'essentiel de l'actu
moi je vous retrouve lundi pour une
nouvelle édition du journal
je vous souhaite donc une excellente
soirée un très bon week end